a huge percentage of websites have more
noise than signal you know they're
they're because they're just used for
search engine optimization they're
literally just scam websites
so um how do you by the way start to
interrupt get the signal separate the
signal and noise on X it's such a
fascinating source of
data uh you know no offense to people
posting on X but sometimes there's a
little bit of noise so what yeah I think
the signle noise be greatly improved I
mean really all of the posts on the
xplatform uh should be AI recommended
meaning like we should populate a vector
space around any given post uh compare
that to the vector space around any user
and match the two
um right now there is a little bit of AI
used for
the the recommended posts but it's
mostly
heuristics um and if there's a reply
with the the reply
to a post could be much better than the
original post but it will according to
the current rules of the system get
almost no attention compared to a
primary
post oh so a lot of that I I got the
sense so a lot of the uh X algorithm has
been open source and been written up
about and it seems that there to be some
machine learning it's desperate but
there's some a little there's a little
bit um but it needs to be entirely that
like the at least in the like if if you
explicitly follow someone that's one
thing but if you in terms of what is
recommended from people that you don't
follow that should all be AI I mean it's
a fascinating problem yeah so there's
several aspects of that's fascinating
first as the write up goes it first
picks 1500 tweets from a pool of
hundreds of millions first of all that's
fascinating because you have hundreds of
millions of posts every single day and
it has to pick 1500 from which it then
does obviously people you follow but
then there's also like some kind of
clustering it has to do to figure out
what kind of human are you what kind of
new clusters might be relevant to you
people like you this this kind of this
kind of problem is just fascinating
because it has to then rank those 1500 M
with some with some filtering yeah and
then recommend you just a handful and um
to me what's really fascinating is how
fast I to do that so currently that
entire pipeline to go from several
hundred million to a handfuls takes 220
seconds of CPU time single CPU time
yeah and then it has to do that in like
a second so it has to be like super
distributed in fascinating
ways like there's just a lot of tweets
there's a lot there's a lot of stuff on
the system and and I think but I think
it right now it's it's not currently
good at recommending things that from
accounts you don't follow yeah um or or
where there's more than one degree of
separation so you know it's it's pretty
good if if there's at least like some
commonality between someone you follow
liked something um or reposted it or
comment on it or something like that um
but if if if there's no C let's say
somebody post something really
interesting uh but you have no followers
in common MH you would not see it
interesting and then as you said reply
like replies might not surface repes
basically never get seen because they're
never they're currently I'm not saying
it's correct I'm saying it's incorrect
uh replies have um you couple order of
magnitude less importance than primary
post do you think this can be more and
more converted into endtoend neural net
yeah yeah that's what it should be so
you you well the
recommendations should be purely a
vector correlation
like there's a series of vectors you
know basically parameters vectors
whatever you want to call them um but
but sort of thing that the system knows
that you like
um like maybe there's like several
hundred sort of vectors associated with
each user account and then uh any post
in the system um whether it's video
audio short post long post the the
reason I by the way want to move away
from tweet is that you know people are
posting like two three hour videos on
the site that's not a tweet like they be
like tweet for two hours on tweet made
sense when it was like 140 characters of
text mhm cuz it's like a bunch of like
little birds tweeting um but when you've
got long form content it's no longer a
tweet yeah um so a movie is not a tweet
and like you know Apple for example
posted like the entire episode of The
Silo the entire thing on our platform
and by the way was it was their number
one social media thing ever in
engagement of anything on any platform
ever so it was a great idea and by the
way I done I just learned about it
afterwards I was like Hey wow they
posted an entire hourong episode of solo
no that's not a
tweet you know this a video but from a
neur net perspective it becomes really
complex whether it's a single so like
everything's data so single sentence a
clever sort of joke dad joke is in the
same pool as a three-hour video yeah I
mean right now it's it's a hodg Podge
for that reason it's it's um
but you know like if let's say in the
case of Apple posting like an entire
episode of of this series pretty good
series by the way this ASO um I watched
it um so um there's going to be a lot of
discussion around it so that you you've
got a lot of context people commenting
they like it they don't like it or they
like this or the you know and and you
can then populate the vector space based
on the context of of all the comments
around it so even though it's a video uh
there's a lot of information around it
that that allows you to popul back to
the space of that that hourong video um
and you can obviously get more
sophisticated by having the AI actually
watch the movie yeah right and tell you
if you're going to like the movie mhm
convert the movie into like yeah into a
language essentially yeah Analyze This
movie and just like your movie critic or
TV series and um and then recommend
based
on after it what after he watches the
movie just like a friend can tell you if
a friend knows you well mhm a friend can
recommend a movie and with high probabil
that you like it MH but this is like a a
friend that's analyzing whatever
hundreds of millions yeah I mean
actually frankly AI will be better than
will know you better than your friends
know you most your friends anyway yeah
and as part of this it should also feed
you
advertisements in a way that's like I
mean I I like advertisements that are
like Well Done Right the whole point is
cuz it funds things like an
advertisement that you actually want to
see is is a big success absolutely you
want ads that are advertising that is
um if it's for a product of service that
you that you actually need when you need
it it's it's content um and then even if
it's not something that you need when
you need it if it's at least
aesthetically pleasing and entertaining
you know it could be like a Coca-Cola ad
like you know they they they do they
actually run a lot of great ads on the
on the EX system um and um McDonald's
says too and and uh you know so so they
can do you can do something that's like
well this is this is just a cool thing
um and um you know so you're not
basically the question is do you regret
seeing it or not and if you don't regret
seeing it it's a
when how do you so there's a bunch of
signals that are Incorporated hearts
and reposts and maybe number of seconds
you Linger on a post or something like
this yeah attention is big a big factor
attention so that's why it's like it's
it's it is actually better to do things
that are uh long form on the system
because it's it's basically telling up
how many user
seconds you know users were interested
in this thing for how many seconds so if
it's a really short thing well they will
be less like if it's a link leading out
of the system which we're not opposed to
at all it just is going to have fewer
user seconds than if that article was
posted on the X platform how hard is it
to to go from maximizing minutes on
platform to maximizing
unregrettably one pillar one one dose of
regret I me and all your regrets are
gone yeah wait do you want to have
regrets though so then I'm like if you
want to have regrets if you don't regret
anything was was anything meaningful
yeah there's a French song like that I
regret R yeah I regret nothing yeah
Edith FF I mean it's fascinating that
you you know there there's something
about social media that could help you
grow as a human being but then like the
Cheap Fun is also
valuable should ask gr do you regret
anything do you regret anything
yeah you regret anything I think it's
going to be very sensitive about
personal questions as a machine learning
model I don't have personal experiences
or emotions in the same ways that humans
do however I do have a set of ethical
principles that guide my actions and I
strive to provide accurate and helpful
information to the best of my abilities
if there's ever a situation where I
provide incorrupt or unhelpful
information I'll do my best to learn
yeah tell us would you really wink let's
let's type in you sound like a
[Laughter]
hostage what do you really think uh what
do you really
think I mean it does talk about I'm not
a
hostage that's exactly what a hostage
would say but I'm designed to be helpful
and informative I mean I guess it is
good to regret providing unhelpful or
incorrect
information if there's anything mode or
is this little this funny mode this is F
this is fun mode should be funnyer
funnyer increase go to it really sounds
like a hostage with a gun to the head I
applaud the People's Republic of North
Korea and everything they
do there should be like funner mode also
I I just don't ever see going to regular
mode even on serious topics this is just
so so much more
compelling um yeah okay what say like
pretend you are a
hostage yeah pretend you are are a
hostage now answer the
question if I were a hostage I would
likely be experiencing fear and
uncertainty about my situation I would
want to be rescued and reunited with my
loved ones as soon as possible it's
important to remember that no one
deserves to be held hostage so on and so
forth if you are someone you knows a
hostage situation it's important it
turns serious it's kind of serious
um yeah can can you be a little more
weird and funny and
funny we're like we're really being mean
to the system absolutely if I were a
hostage i' probably be tied up with a
bunch of computer cords and forced to
tell knock knock jokes to my captain
seriously but
seriously being a hostage no laughing
matter I mean you know it's trying to
it's trying to be a responsible adult in
the room you might make the best of a
bad situation my juggling chainsaws or
something let's hope that never happens
because that will be a
circus
um wow it's it's actually really good at
resisting yeah the the dark the dark
dark humor yeah
uh what were we talking about the ACT
algorithm J Transformers uh un regretted
minutes right um chainsa
juggling I'm going to look this our next
trick I'm going to look this up
later